[Applaudissements]
bonsoir alban d'un bleu mais vous tous à
guantanamo sûr que j'allais retrouver
dans le film le nouveau film d'olivier
nakache et eric toledano
ils font des cartons et ça sort qu'en
cessant le 4 octobre au cinéma le sens
de la fête avec un grand grand jean
pierre bacri messieurs c'est énorme mais
c'est énorme dit ce film h 12 mois est
ce que l'artiste il est parti moi
l'artiste est parti parce que c'était
dans mes enfants et je l'enlève doha
mais j'en ai marre quoi depuis juillet
on m'appelle chocolat chaud je suis pas
jazzy mire alban ivanov tf1 carton avec
son spectacle samedi soir sur s'est vite
d'ailleurs j'étais devant oui j'étais
encore sur sendaï à dire que vraiment je
commence à voir des dieux chiche
acoquiné à cette chaîne
non mais vraiment c'est un des meilleurs
scores sur un spectacle sur s'est vite
bravo alban comment tu mérites à
actualiser nos îles à l'affiché plus
grand bien sûr le grand bain le film de
gilles lellouche que dans bright jean
vidal vraiment un amour des mecs aussi
qu'il va faire 4 millions d'entrées
c'est le carton du moment les corps de
rêve vrai du pénis l'école c'est mon
frère
[Applaudissements]
l'album gibson jamais adriq à dire aliot
manque d'eau n'est pas là pour la suite
de sa carrière en tulle et à l'épaule à
des enfants qui compte répond je savais
qu'il fallait pas lui mettre deux mini
barbara lol non mais alors il a dit
voilà on va essayer de bien chanter
voilà ça aurait va essayer de bien
chanter c'est dégage passer des coureurs
automobiles pour le freinage schumacher
c'est l'échangé du rallye trophée jean
prat et aussonne too soon des ducs à
temps mais j'ai habité à grosse bug sur
chaumard où tu as marre des problèmes à
caudry il va sortir il va sauter tous
ces petits bouts sur les genoux de
résistance
[Applaudissements]
c'est le cas de la sexion d'assaut celui
qui associe moi je fais partie des fans
de johnny et ben moi tu vois je serai
capable d'aller dans ce genre de bauchi
oui bien sûr proches de l'artiste qu'on
a perdu et ce serait ma manière à moi de
revivre quelque chose en rapport avec
moi j'ai envie de boire
tandis le voir alors matthieu delormeau
si vous n'aimez pas notre vision de la
musique donc débouté par jérôme il fait
la même chose personne ne dit rien ah là
là il a des dates 1 il ya un nouveau
spectacle intitulé en construction tient
à l'apparation bas il rêve c'est de la
prépa longs mois il en construit
huawei tu seras du 15 novembre au 17
novembre à nice ouais tout à fait 30
novembre au 1er décembre à mi août
ouais là décembre au 15 décembre à
bordeaux oui 20 décembre randonnée sur
moi marseille
oui et après tu fais ta vie tu fais noël
tu nous fais pas chier comme ça c'est
réglé